-You're up. Come pull the mic
and let's see what game you got.
Don't be nervous.
You'll be funny. You'll nail it.
Come on.
[ Beeping ]
♪♪
Musical Genre Challenge.
Perfect.
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge ♪
-We all know how this one works.
You're gonna get a song title
and a totally different
musical genre,
then you have to sing
that song in that style.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Beeping ]
♪♪
Justin is watching tonight.
-Stop it!
-And he loves Broadway.
-You're killing me.
-He really wants to see
"Sexy Back"
done in a Broadway style.
-Oh, my God.
-By the one and only.
I mean, will you do it?
Can we try it?
-Yes!
-Let's do that.
Alright, hit your spot.
Jam band, whenever you're ready,
go for it.
-Give me a little somethin',
Mama.
♪♪
-♪ I'm bringing sexy back ♪
♪ Them other boys don't know
how to act ♪
♪ I think it's special,
what's behind your back ♪
♪ So turn around,
and I'll pick up the slack ♪
♪ Take it to the chorus ♪
♪ Come on ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪ Come here, girl,
come to the back ♪
-Come on now.
-♪ VIP, drinks on me ♪
♪ Let me see
what you're twerking with ♪
-You better sing.
-♪ Look at those hips, girl ♪
♪ You make me smile ♪
♪ So come here, child ♪
-[ Whistles ]
-♪ And get your sexy on ♪
-♪ Go ahead, be gone with it ♪
-♪ Get your sexy on ♪
-Wow!
-♪ And get your sexy on ♪
-♪ I'm bringing sexy back ♪
-Oh!
♪ Them other boys don't know
how to act ♪
♪ I think it's special,
what's behind your back ♪
-♪ Go ahead, be gone with it ♪
-♪ So turn around
and pick up the slack ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I'm bringing sexy back ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think she won.
I think she won.
-Give her all the points.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Renée Elise Goldsberry,
come on!
Oh, my goodness!
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Oh, my God.
-Unbelievable.
That was unbelievable.